- [Interviewer] All right, Sylvia.
Sylvia, where'd you grow
up? Where are you from?
- I actually grew up in
Lake Forest, California
in South Orange County. (chuckles)
- [Interviewer] Okay, you're
an Orange County girl.
- [Sylvia] (chuckling)
Yeah, born and raised.
- [Interviewer] Okay, and
what got you down to Skid Row?
- I actually came to LA to go to rehab.
And I was in rehab there in East LA,
and then I was sober for three years,
and then I relapsed when
my grandfather died.
And I had met somebody out here,
and his mother is actually
out here on Skid Row.
And when I relapsed, we
came and visited her,
and we kinda just got stuck down here.
So, that was about three years ago.
- [Interviewer] What was your
drug, or what is your drug?
- Heroin and meth, and now
I'm on fentanyl too, so.
- [Interviewer] Oh wow.
How'd you get introduced
to drugs like that
down in Orange County?
- I started using drugs at
like 13, and I partied a lot,
and was, it just progressed
into the next drug, next drug,
and eventually, I was sitting
in my best friend's house
with her mom, who, she was smoking heroin,
and I was already on
meth, and I seen her mom,
and I asked her mom for a hit,
and her mom gave me a hit.
And from there on, I just
became out of control
with my heroin habit, yeah. (chuckles)
- [Interviewer] Now, tell
me about your childhood.
You grew up with both parents, one parent?
- No, actually, I was
adopted at the age of six.
At two years old, I was
taken from my mom's custody.
She had been with a guy
who was an alcoholic
and addicted to the crystal,
and he would physically
abuse me really bad,
like step on me, almost like,
almost borderline torture.
When I was taken, the day I
was taken from her custody,
he had stepped on my head,
and he had an imprint,
imprinted not just on my
skin, but on my skull,
the bottom of his Timberland boot.
And so, I was taken from my mom's custody,
and it was a long custody battle.
I was in group homes, foster homes.
Eventually, my mom's aunt and
uncle were able to take me in.
And it was like a fairytale-like family.
It was four kids, two boys,
two girls, in Orange County,
with a beautiful home,
and had the green grass,
and the pets and everything,
the mom, the dad.
And it was like any child
would want to be adopted into that family.
But a month after I was adopted,
my so-called father,
adopted father, had left.
He left my mom, five kids.
She was a stay-at-home mom.
He just up and left,
and she had to go from
being a stay-at-home mom
to providing for all of us, you know?
And I love my mom for that
because she did it, you know?
- [Interviewer] But
it's not your real mom.
- No, that's my adopted mom.
- [Interviewer] Adopted mom.
- Yeah.
She didn't let that stop her
from raising her kids, you know?
She went to work, she provided for us.
We were able to continue to stay
in that Orange County lifestyle, you know?
I can't say that we were spoiled,
but we had everything we needed.
And now that I'm older
and I look back, man,
we lived on a lake,
and my mom was able to do that, you know?
It wasn't easy for her,
but she was able to do it.
And I respect her so much
now for that, you know?
But unfortunately, for whatever
reason, I'm the only one,
out of all kids, to end up
on drugs like I am, you know?
(chuckles)
- [Interviewer] When did you
get first introduced to it?
- [Sylvia] I don't know, I
feel like it was always around,
just with the group of
kids that I was around.
I wasn't hanging out
with the popular kids.
I was hanging out with
the stoners, you know?
It just, the culture of
drugs was always around me,
and I glamorized it.
Heroin addiction, in my life,
in my mind, was glamorized.
It was like a beautiful tragedy.
Almost every girl I knew wanted
to be that dope-fiend girl,
for whatever reason,
'cause she always got saved, or, you know?
So, it was always glamorized
in my head, in my life.
But it's not so glamorous,
(chuckling) you know?
It's hard, you know?
- [Interviewer] So where
are you living now?
- [Sylvia] In Skid Row.
- You're on the street?
- (chuckles) In tents, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And what
do you do for money?
What a lot of the girls are doing?
- No, actually, I don't do that,
and I don't know, I think
it's God or whatever.
I will hustle, I will sell
things, I will sell, I sell dope.
Yeah, I chose to,
'cause, as messed up as it sounds,
I'm good at selling dope. (chuckles)
I sell heroin, I sell
crystal, I sell fentanyl.
But it's hard to be a female out here
'cause none of these dope dealers,
they're all gang members, men,
they don't want to see
a female up-do them.
'Cause any person out here
would rather buy drugs
from a pretty-looking girl
than a hardcore gang member.
And so, I get,
it's hard for me to make any
money out here selling dope
because they don't want to
see me make it, you know?
The crazy thing is, out here,
I came out here with my
boyfriend at the time,
and me and him ended up breaking up.
He turned gay on me. (chuckles)
And I met somebody else.
And I never thought I would fall in love
with somebody on Skid Row,
but he's the only person in my life
that's ever tried to get
me off drugs, you know?
And even my family left
me out here for dead.
I hate my family.
I don't want nothing to ever do with them,
because I never hurt them,
I never robbed from them,
I never stole from them,
but they left me out here.
And when I asked them for help,
no, I didn't ask them for money,
I didn't ask them for anything,
I asked them for a program,
to get me out of here,
they denied me of that.
But this man, who was a
hardcore gang member, a killer,
who has no heart, is the only man
that's ever offered to
help me get out of this.
And a lot of people
have the wrong conception
of people out here.
When I first came out
here, I was so judgmental.
I was like, "Fuck living in a tent.
I'm gonna sleep in my car."
When I lost my car, I
had to stay in a tent.
But now, my family that I
choose to have, my family
are these people out here that I met.
My sister, not my sister in my family,
'cause I don't, those
aren't my family no more.
But my sister out here,
she's the only one
that's ever encouraged me
to keep going and keep
doing better, you know?
And it's weird because
my whole outlook on life
has changed, being out here.
I don't want to die out here.
I don't want to be another girl
found in a tent, burned alive, you know?
I've had one of my closest
homeboys die in a tent,
go into the coroner's
office as a John Doe.
And I don't want that to be me. (sniffles)
And my family, they
don't know where I'm at.
They don't know if I'm alive,
and I don't care because
they don't care to find out.
I have a Facebook, they can find me.
But these people that I'm now
choosing to make my family,
they check on me every day.
They make sure I'm okay.
They make sure I'm fed, clothed, healthy.
My boyfriend now, he,
'cause I had an eating
disorder, I wouldn't eat,
he makes sure I eat every day.
And it's little things like that
that people don't know matter
to somebody, (sniffles)
but they matter, you know?
And I've had my heart changed
for people out here (sniffles)
because I'm one of these people out here.
I never thought I'd be
somebody to live on Skid Row.
But I can say that I stay on Skid Row.
But it gave me a heart,
a heart that I never had,
a heart to care for somebody
that nobody wants to care for.
My ex-boyfriend's mom has been out here
since she was 15 years old.
She has HIV and lung
cancer, and she's dying.
Nobody checks on her. Nobody feeds her.
All they do is feed her crack.
One day I'm gonna find her
dead in her tent. I know I am.
And what is anybody gonna do about it?
People are dying out here every day,
and it's like, what is
anybody doing about it?
I'm just one girl stuck up
here. I try to make it home.
I don't know what my next step is,
but I don't, I'm not
gonna be out here forever.
I'm 25 years old, and I don't
want to stay stuck out here.
Some of my closest friends are
those people that talk about
how they were gang members and murderers.
And my best friend,
she's been a prostitute
since she was 14 years old.
But I love her because she's
real, and she has a heart.
(sniffles) I always thought
I was better than everybody
because I was from Orange County,
because I grew up in a good
lifestyle, a good home,
but I'm not better than nobody.
I'm just as low as everybody else.
And I'm okay with-
- [Interviewer] You're just
as free as everybody else.
- I'm okay with that,
because when you're at your lowest point
is where you get your greatest strength.
And my next move in my life,
people are gonna be shocked
because I've set in my
heart my next steps.
Three things to keep secret
are your finances,
your love life, and your next move.
And my next move is gonna
be my greatest move.
And my life isn't gonna
be nothing what it is now,
and I'm gonna make sure of it,
because nobody else can
but me, you know? (sobs)
And I miss my family every day,
and it hurts me, but fuck them,
because they didn't care
if I was alive or not.
Every single one of my
siblings have gotten married,
and I'm never gonna be in
one of those wedding books.
And I'm okay with that,
because they're not
gonna be in mine either.
And it's kind of like a harsh
thing to hear, or for to say,
but it's really how I feel, you know?
Because I never wronged them,
I never did them any wrong,
but they treated me like I
did, and that hurt. (sniffles)
And it's just, every day I wake up,
and I see where I'm at,
and it's a harsh reality of
what I chose to do with my life.
I haven't done anything.
I have not graduated high school.
I have not accomplished
anything in my life.
But that doesn't mean my life is over.
I don't know very much, I've
not been very many places,
but I'm about to live a life
that I could never imagine,
because I'm gonna choose that.
I'm not a mom.
I'm not a wife or whatever.
It's just me, myself, and I.
And I'm gonna make sure that that one day
when I do become a mom,
that I'm gonna be the greatest mom ever,
because I never had that,
and I'm gonna make sure my
children have that. (sobs)
It's a harsh reality out here,
when you see your friends die,
when you see the people
around you strung out,
the people you love the most so hurt,
but all you can do is try
to be a light for them,
even when you need someone
to be a light for you.
(sniffles)
- [Interviewer] Sylvia,
thanks so much for talking.
Good luck with everything you do in life.
- Thank you.